I love the idea of this movie that
people may not be what they seem is that
a fun concept for you to play with as a
director yeah I think it is because well
it's not only is that a fun concept the
player that's a director it's it's what
make it's it's what makes really good
stories for movies because they're
universal themes this idea that we may
be passionately in love with someone and
we don't really know who they are
yes that's that happens in real life a
lot and you get to identify with that
story yeah made me think about how love
can sometimes be an act yeah whether
you're not sure in on the actor yeah and
love is a complicated and sometimes
messy situation
the phrase strong female character gets
used a lot but in what way do you feel
Marianne is both feminine and very
strong she's in this extreme situation
and in this extreme situation there is
something that is even more extreme
which is love it will change the course
of her life and and she will face
choices that will improve her strength
and and and emotions Robert Zemeckis is
obviously such a gifted director I mean
looking at his filmography some
incredible movies in your mind what is
his greatest talent choosing very
complex and yet authentic and very
loving characters when we met he told me
you know I've never I've never told a is
such a strong love story before and the
humility he had but also the burning
desire to tell the story and to tell it
the right way was so beautiful to watch
I love you with all my heart we suspect
your wife as a German spy if she is
execute her with your own hand
you